You are not a victim. Nobody made you pick up the phone and tweet
about it. You are not a victim. >> So basically this whole
thing is just a on tech. Talk to this person.
>> WAIT, I DIDN'T KNOW HE COVERED THIS. NOBODY TOLD me
he covered this. Guys never met a single on earth he can't empathize
with. That's that's his superpower. Okay.
So yesterday,
Tekone seems to have posted something
that likely violates his protective order. Okay.
Y'all ever heard of a assault victim complain they weren't getting
enough?
Um, one, yeah, there's like like that could absolutely happen.
One, you had a relationship before she was assaulted,
right? Anyway, so he tweets this out. This is obviously referencing
her uh when she referenced him. I do believe this is basically
a cut and dry version uh like a cut and dry example of violating
the protective order. It's possible he could get away with it.
It's possible,
but it's pretty it's pretty cut and dry that this is like on
its face a violation of the protective order. Okay, he's not
supposed to talk about her online. He's explicitly barred from
talking about her on social media. Okay,
Tone is possibly violating his 10-year protection order and subweeting
about Pink
though the tweet wasn't archived as it's been posted by multiple
people and the replies to the tweet or sorry, the replies to
the tweet were archived.
These were all posted by three different people with history
log replies to the tweet which were archived and the tweet itself
on Teone's profile. So, people had it archived like have their
replies archived. Now, luckily for us, okay,
in fact, it did get archived. It just took a minute, but it did
get archived.
All right. Tecton's post violating his protection order was in
fact archived, which wasn't certain yesterday.
Yes, it was archived. A third party has archived it, has saved
it. Okay, so it's no longer We're no longer thinking, "Oh, was
this real? Could it have been photoshopped?" Nope. Nope. It's
just It's there. He tweeted it. He's a Okay. Total [__]
I don't know why he did it. Very, very goofy fellow. Okay. Misk
won again in his war against Techone. Absolutely he won again,
dude. I'm not I'm probably not going to read too many replies
right now, but we have it we have it archived. It happened. It's
definitely a violation. Now, you could probably go look something
up under Texas law and try to see, I guess, whether or not that
kind of like tweet, whether or not like replying to something
in a public forum is is still a violation. Either way, it's a
total lack of impulse control again from TechOne, right? Just
zero impulse control. Immediately like fires the tweet out the
second somebody shows him the clip, just loses his mind, gets
super angry, and goes and tweets this out again. Like this is
this is a lack of impulse control of somebody who does do like
significant
Nobody's a good person who's got this little impulse control.
There's just nobody like this who's a good person. It just it
can't happen basically. Okay. All right. Now, what
do you think was the cause of this? Well, it was Pink being on
a dating show. That's what it was. Okay.
Pink was on a dating show. They they did like a dating show kind
of thing. Her and her friends.
Tecton saw this and he got very very
angry. All right. Now, here's the clip with respect to Tecton
specifically. We got a chronic Sonic snot no swagger tweet here
rather and and 1.1 million views. This popped off. Holy moly.
Massive tweet. Pop the balloon. Kind of the same set. Not pop
the balloon though. No. All right.
Yes, he did have a specific
rule against making social media posts about her. Yes, he did.
Oh, so she can subweet me, but I can't subweet her. I think there's
a criticism of Pink here that is not that,
but it's close to that. And we'll we'll get into it when we actually
watch the clip here. Okay. >> I like I haven't had sex.
>> Did uh did you know the the last guy not have sex with
you or what? What? >> Well, he was only attracted to anime
women. So, but it looked pretty anime kawaii. What do >> you
mean he was only attracted to anime women? Was he like addicted
to >> Kai? SO HE WAS ADDICTED TO
>> SO he was addicted so much he didn't want to have with
the real thing. >> Something along those lines. >> If
you suffer from this, call 1800
>> That was horrible. That was That was that guy's moment
to say something witty >> from this. >> And he said
that >> 1800
yikes.
>> Okay. All right. And Bella, what kind of guy are we
looking for for uh Pink? A guy with hair. Number one. >> What's
this whole like, you know, bald guys thing? >> Bald guys
are fine, but her ex was bald, so she needs a change of pace.
>> I could see why that would upset him, especially when,
you know, Pink has a protective order or whatever. I could see
why Tek would be upset. But what I can't see is why TeeOne would
with no impulse control immediately tweet something and violate
his protective order. Like that's How does this get you so angry
that you immediately violate your protective order? How?
Stop pretending not to under to not understand. It's manipulative.
What do you mean?
Well, sorry. I I've said that he doesn't have any self self-control.
He's got no impulse control at all. But I just I don't know what
he's doing, man. The weak man with thin skin. He truly is. He
truly truly is. The bald comment probably sent him. I don't know
the thing. He So again, we go back to the original tweet.
Let me grab my my tweet on it. We go back to the original tweet.
Y'all ever heard of a assault victim complain that they weren't
getting enough.
That's the thing that upset him here was, and by the way, during
that part, she's not on him. Somebody else brings it up, right?
She's just saying, "I miss I want to have again." That's all
she's
So he got mad at again somebody else like sort of bringing that
up. The guy asked, "Wait, did your last boyfriend not say anything?
Not do anything with you or Yeah, it's she didn't even bring
it up." And then she does bring up if he was mad about, you know,
her talking about his addiction,
then I would I would almost understand him posting even. But
that's the part where like, yeah, I I can imagine assault victims.
I don't know if Tone knows this, but after being assaulted, people
still want to have sex. Realistically, Teone should know this
because he himself is a victim. Okay. He is literally the thing
he's complaining about. Yes. People often complain that they
aren't getting enough. Even people who've been actually.
Yes, Ste. It's possible. It turned him off forever. It really
did. Okay. Tactical Templar went live. He covered the Snot Swagger
tweet. >> So, let's talk about this. Is Tee going to jail?
This is a very interesting thing that popped up and we have a
lot to talk about as it relates to this.
So, without further ado, ladies and gentlemen, we're just going
to get right in. I'm sure most of you already know the details.
You already know the the pre-check. I'm just going to assume
that. So, uh yeah, let's just get into it. Brothers, there is
something fundamentally wrong with our society when you can have
a woman like this who is the ex-girlfriend of Tee go out there
and talk [__] about him, but Tee isn't allowed to
respond. Now, the people that don't like Tee, the people who
are the >> Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Before
you talk about me,
why can't Tech respond?
Why
can we get to that part? Why can't Teone respond? Wait, what
did he what happened that he can't respond? I feel like we're
we're skipping something over we're skipping over something here,
>> Out there and talk [__] about him. But Teone
isn't allowed to respond. Now, the people that don't like TeeOne,
the people who are the a loggers, the people that are the detractors,
the backbenchers, the haters, whatever you want to call them,
they love this stuff because the legal system being used.
I confess that I do love watching Teone get [__]
on. I do confess that I love watching Teone burn his own career
down, his own life down. I I love watching these things. I confess
all he would have to do is not be
a zero impulse control like
I zero impulse control like mentally ill BPD guy and I wouldn't
get anything. I wouldn't get anything out of this. I'd get nothing.
It's only him making bad decisions that gives me any pleasure
in this situation. Okay. If he was just making content, commenting
on things, and not getting himself into trouble, I'd have nothing
to cover. It's very funny and also entirely his fault. Yeah.
It's like, dude,
what are we what are we doing here? All he had to do is not respond
>> against somebody that they don't like. They just think
it's an automatic win.
They're very shortsighted. They're very emotional. They're very
The problem is people like me can see things beyond 15 minutes
in front of me. >> Oh. Oh. Oh, I see what he's going to
say. You don't think about how this could be used against other
people.
No, I just don't really have a problem with a guy who was, you
know, they found reason to believe that he had assaulted and
stalked her not being able to comment when she has a little like
side comment on some show she's on. I don't I don't I don't think
he's earned that right. He's lost that right. Right. Through
his bad action, which has been far more egregious than any tweet
or any comment on a show. He has lost that
It's not about like, oh, should I do I think you should ever
be barred from being able to respond to somebody's talk about
you? No. Generally, no. But if you are found by a court that
it's, you know, it's reasonable to believe that you would have
assaulted them and stalked them and you get a 10-year protective
order filed against you because you couldn't provide any evidence
of any of your like anything you said you had. When these things
all come together, this confluence of factors, yes, I think that's
fine, right? I I do think it's fine. I don't think it's actually
a problem. If somebody I liked were in this exact same situation,
I would maybe have empathy for it sucking for them. I'd have
no empathy for them going out and destroying themselves by tweeting
about it. Zero. Zero. You are not a victim. Nobody made you pick
up the phone and tweet about it. You are not a victim.
Which these people just can't. These people live for the next
15 minutes.
But as a society,
this is not the way that we should be operating
where you can have a woman who goes out there and somebody, but
there's nothing that you can say in return because well, that's
harassment. That's violating an order because some radical feminist
judge.
He's gonna lay out all the think before you sleep stuff again
with no
Hey, why
the the real question for Tactical Templar, I guess, would be
something like why did Tek say repeatedly that he had all of
the evidence he needed to exonerate himself and then what is
he holding it for? That he didn't present it to the judge at
the trial so that he didn't get a protective order against him.
Right? He said he had all of this evidence. He said he had it
in the bag. He told all of you stupid marks this, okay? While
he grifted, while he while he conned all of you and then he apparently
presented none of it in court. What What's the strategy here?
What's going on? >> It has a history of bias. There's a
history of problems on this particular issue.
Gave
a protective order. >> Oh, she has a history of bias on
this issue.
Have you analyzed her court cases or did you just take somebody's
word for
I feel like they what what is the story with the judge again?
I can't remember. I know that she like had some sort of she
said that assault was like a a big thing or I don't even remember
what the judge's thing was. I do know it wasn't analyzing her
cases to see like what her rulings have been like. I do know
that
>> even though the evidence and the information at hand
was inconsistent, it didn't line up, there were things that this
woman said
that didn't match her previous behavior or the previous things
that she said to other people or the text messages or the fact
that she was telling Teone how much she loved him and she was
just >> Wait until this guy finds out that like is it not
the overwhelming
Maybe not overwhelming majority, dude.
Happens most between like people you trust and partners. Like
that's where people get.
That's that's where it happens.
It's a lot of people you the people you love are the people you're
around most. The people who are most likely to do some kind of
crime like that to you. Saying you love him even after the the
conduct occurred is not dispositive of it being ever. Full stop.
She couldn't wait to get back from the hospital to be with like
there are so many things about this. Whatever you think about
tactone,
the fact is that we should have a system where if you are guilty
of
assault, if you're guilty of being a pedo, if you're guilty of
any of these things, you should be punished according to the
law. You should be in jail. I
why why does he think civil courts exist and why do they why
did they have like a lower um standard of evidence generally
and then for this protective order why there's even lower standard
of evidence for that this is the way society's decided to handle
these cases right it is a lower standard of evidence but
where the crime would come in where where a like a miscarriage
of justice would come in is if te were punished as though he
were charged in criminal court but he's not being punished that
Okay, he doesn't get to have guns and he doesn't get to tweet
about Pink Chu. Those are the only two things he can't do, right?
Well, there are a couple other things around like contacting
Pink Chu or being around Pingchu, but those are the only two
things he can't do. Those are the only two things he's taken
that are taken from him. Realistically, he hates this woman.
Why would he want either of those things being a part of his
life? Well, the guns maybe, but that's more on the schizophrenia
to be honest with you. I said the guns, but but it's just he
literally like the only thing taken from him with regards to
Pink is just the ability to tweet about her. That's it. He's
not being thrown in jail. He's not had his career destroyed.
It's just you massively overstating it. His career wasn't destroyed
for this. It's It's wild to me that people will say like this,
right?
That people will say, "Oh, well, uh, the only way you can punish
somebody is a criminal conviction." No, you should never ever
You should support anyone who doesn't have a criminal conviction.
That's insane. the it shouldn't be for these braindead
drooling probably imbred idiots on the internet like these people
to be the ones that are like well we are the moral arbittors
you're not the moral arbittors you never have been you never
will be you are morally repugnant you are the judge is the moral
arbiter that's literally her job she's she's doing the approximation
of like morality for for these people in a court case right that's
like her she's trying to find something that's just and makes
Turns out what was just and made sense for Tee was not getting
guns for 10 years and not being able to tweet about Pink or
if it's true that Teone did actually
um force himself on his girlfriend, which I don't think he did
based on the evidence, but if you think he did, then you should
be encouraging this woman to go to the police. Oh, but she did
go to police, but she decided to back out because she was scared.
No, that's there was no evidence to this. Even the police understood
that. But if you think that there is >> the Did the police
close the case? Then there's I I can't do the debate. >> You should
be encouraging her to go to the police and you should be encouraging
them
to go after Tee
to put him in jail, which I would I would support if Tee if Tee
actually did that. If he forced himself on a girl, I would say
do it. So, I guess the thing you'd have to ask Tactical Templar
here is how would you prove that? How would you go about proving
that? Let's say he did. Just assume he did for a second. And
what evidence would there be of that? Tactical Templar, please.
I in your infinite wisdom, could you let me know?
He He
Now, what evidence is there? What evidence would there be? Uh,
the the answer is none. I' I've said this before and it's up,
but you could probably get away with that kind of thing with
a partner. You shouldn't do it. Obviously, not advocating for
doing it, but if you just do that in the middle of a relationship
and the partner doesn't leave you immediately and go to the police
immediately, that can't be the line for now you did nothing wrong.
By the way, the filler being lopsided is already documented.
We have that evidence already, right?
That evidence is all there. Tactone is admitted to it. So, anything
he got from the DNA is already admitted to. He's admitted to
this, right? That evidence is all there. I don't think the cops
could prosecute that. That's not beyond a reasonable doubt.
Bits on the story. And I'm not as emotionally compromised as
all of you freaks. Because here's the reality. It will be used
against you. How many more examples do you guys need to see of
men who are in much more affluent and much more protected positions
than you being taken down? Do you need to Why do you think Teone
was taken down by this?
Where where is Tect taken down?
Where was he taken down? I honestly It's just crazy. Where was
he taken down at all? He still got like 3,000 viewers, three
or 4,000 concurrent viewers on YouTube.
Where's the takeown coming in? >> See, before you realize
that it's not a joke. Just because you don't like somebody
doesn't mean it's a good thing when something like the government
is used against them.
>> So, he supports Msk.
Uh, it would be funny to see what he thinks about Msk at this
point. I know why I support Miskf and don't support Techone.
But I would I'd be interested to see this guy say that like,
hey, everybody who Msk who calls him any bad words, those people
are all wrong. Although I will say I do believe legal mindset
flipped on this, right? A bunch of people have flipped on this
and said like, "Oh, actually you shouldn't go after Miz on this
at all."
it is kind of changing. >> So you can get a couple chuckles
off of the internet.
Now, let's take a look at what she actually said.
And we'll take a look at what TechOne said. And I have some criticisms
for TechOne. Believe me, I I have some I have some major criticisms
here. >> Wow. Okay, we're going to check this out. I'm
very excited. But guys, I'm going to get off Twitch early today.
I'm going to go kick fulltime. Full full stream on Kick. Okay.
Head over to kick kick.com/jlk.
I'm going to get off Twitch, guys. We'll see you over on kick.
Okay, kick.com/jstylk.
We'll see you there in just a little bit. Okay. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. >> But this situation makes me very sad
because I see guys constantly getting shafted, getting the short
end of the stick, getting treated like garbage by society, and
then wondering why people tune in to Andrew Tate. It's like,
why? Why would you turn into Andrew Tate? Oh, I don't know. Maybe
because he's talking about things that are >> women occasionally
falsely in this guy's perfect world in women occasionally
accuse somebody falsely of so I have to become a
incredible incredible
you're shocked that men turn into edger tape when this subs allowed
this woman faked the rap now I have to rap okay that's what we
call equivalent exchange okay that is that is equivalent exchange
you. She faked being raped. So now I have to I'm going to become
Andrew Tate.
Weird weird stuff. >> The opposite. >> Very weird
guy >> of whatever this is. This sort of just
oozing postural gaggle of just disgusting simps
and destructive freaks. Like I got to tell you, yeah,
I wish we had better role models in society. I really really
do. But here here's what uh Tekton's uh ex-girlfriend
>> Did uh did you know the the last guy not have or what?
What happened? >> Well, he was only attracted to anime
women. So, but it looked pretty anime kawaii
something like that. You know, >> you mean he was only
attracted to anime women? Was he like addicted to
>> HE WAS ADDICTED TO? YEAH. >> SO, HE was addicted
so much he didn't want to have with the real thing. >> Something
along those lines. >> If you suffer from this, >> Huh.
Isn't that interesting?
So, a guy that was uh the victim of abuse
the I mean, if you want to go into the full thing about Tectum
Wait, wouldn't Hold on.
What? What do you Did you want Pink to say that?
Actually, he was raped as a child, so he was terrified of my
Would that have been appropriate?
How dare she say addicted to which he obviously was.
He was a victim of childhood abuse. God, I wish I wish Pink would
have said that. That would have been way better. >> Like
the guy has been through the
guy's been through the like if you listen to the story him talking
about him being a victim of abuse and then his crazy
cheating
manipulative ex like this whole situation just makes me sick
because on one hand there are criticisms that you could levy
at Teeone. He has no impulse control and he he shouldn't be tweeting
like this, especially with a protective order. >> But even
in the first case, I would have said it's ill advised to do this.
I I actually if I had uh if I had known Teone at the time, I
would have said shut the up and get in contact with a lawyer
if you think this is defamation.
Um you be the one to sue her and don't say a word.
>> Okay, but he didn't do that. Now, that's literally a
huge part of the reason that this protective order got granted
is because he continued to see about her across the internet,
on Twitter, on his streams, in his videos.
That's the problem. You're describing the actual bad conduct
that occurred here.
It's not bad conduct to talk about somebody. It's bad conduct
to consistently despite having some sort of like legal proceeding
happening to consistently go out and see about this person over
and over and over again despite having the initial protective
order f sorry the initial protective order file. It's bad >> cuz
this doesn't help your case. That being said,
Teone has nothing to do with this but they're allowed to sh on
him. They everyone knows who they're talking about
But you're allowed to run down a man's reputation and he's not
allowed to respond. That if that is the society that you want
to live, I fundamentally
dude. Okay. What is um
what's a similar thing here that would happen? I'm trying to
think of something similar. Is there an approximation of this
we could get? Cuz she's not talking about him being a either,
right? She's literally just laughing at him for something else.
I'm trying to think because if she was if she wanted to say that
he was a on this thing then maybe I'd see a problem there because
he's not been you know found
to like a reasonably high standard to have been likely to done
that but she's just kind of talking here. I don't know that I
super care about this,
right? Like, where's the is this
to say this guy who constantly talked about how he thought 9-year-old
anime girls were for that guy to say that guy was addicted to
Is that slander? I don't think it's slander or defamation. It's
not anything like that. Yeah. I
I I'm sorry. He gave up his rights because of his bad actions.
She didn't do the same thing. And now he's trying to get those
rights back. He wants to go in and talk about her. No, you gave
that up and she hasn't done something with regards to the assult
with regards to calling you ault or anything like that such that
you should get those rights back. She's just
Steve, Steve, Steve,
call 1800
yikes.
And this guy's a s. What a loser.
Okay. All right. And Bella, what kind of guy? It's a dating show.
It's literally the content. Yes. Congratulations,
dude. This guy's watching a dating show and he's like, it's like
he this guy's just trying to this woman. Yes. That's literally
what the show is. That's what the show is about. Congratulations.
You've identified the core concept.
>> Guy are we looking for for >> a guy with hair
number one. >> So basically this whole thing is just a
own techone. Now how how pathetic is >> it's soft, dude?
That's the sad thing is it seems it's almost certainly just all
scripted. Nothing would happen from this specific like show.
It's just all scripted.
I It is It is unfortunate to watch. Okay. Now, if you were to
reverse this and Tech Tone were to do something like this and
he he were to go on a show
um
and and you were to to have him asked a bunch of questions like,
"What kind of girl do you think would be good for Tecton?" Well,
uh, not a girl that's more plastic than girl. Uh, not a girl
that's a manipulative. Like if you were to do this thing in
>> You mean like all of you guys have done like think before
you sleep explicitly did and Tech was coordinating with people
to watch that video like exactly that?
Oh yeah. Well, that would sure be bad. By the way, from behind
a protective order, by the way, bro, what? There's no way. you
were to go on a show
um
and and you were to to have him asked a bunch of questions like
what kind of girl do you think would be good for Tecton? Well,
not a girl that's more plastic than girl. Uh not a girl that's
a manipulative. Like if you were to do this thing in reverse,
people would not be okay with it. But because they personally
don't like techone, they're willing to accept all of this sort
of just mindbendingly agre. >> You can say all of that
stuff. Okay. The reason I don't like the plastic surgery comments
is because you dated this woman and you were clearly attracted.
So stop coping. That's my thing. Okay. If you just hated plastic
surgery, that would be fine. But you hate plastic surgery. You
say you hate plastic surgery now because this woman is no longer
your toy. Okay, that's that's why you hate plastic surgery now.
It's not because you actually do. You You're just mad that this
woman is off the plantation. You clearly had no problem with
it when you advocated her getting the implants in the first place,
which I believe came out in the court case. Okay. He's the one,
I believe, who convinced her to get the the boob job. Yeah. And
so for you to come out later and have your friends say, "Oh,
this gross woman, this gross woman who's mostly pl." It's just
a Tech done the same thing. talk about like OF girls with plastic
surgery and
it's just cope. You're just coping. You
So yeah, we're gonna be taking a look at this a a little more
in depth because I mean these people
uh the tweet that potentially violates his protective order.
Y'all ever heard of a SA victim complain they weren't getting
enough? So Teone is not allowed literally he's not allowed to
defend himself. Now, I I wouldn't have posted this or or encouraged
him to post this. I would have said, "You should take this video
and you should send it to your lawyer." I like that would have
been my response. Techone, do not respond to this. Send this
to your lawyer because
this is something that that is, you know, you should probably
get a protective order against her
that she can't talk about you because she now
>> hold on. This is not what protective orders are for.
What does he think protective orders are for? They do actually
take your rights away. They're not granting a protective order
because somebody said mean things about tech toad. You can call
him a bald addicted limp freak all you like.
That's the internet. That's free speech. The reason he lost his
free speech is because he was found to he was found
Oh god, how do I say this with with that language? It's the judge
thought it was reasonably likely, okay,
that he assaulted his doctor. That's why she got the protective
order. His negative
okay,
his
she's not done anything like that that would that would, you
know, amount to a protective order. Nothing close. Sorry, just
reasonable grounds to believe he has aid. That's what I was looking
for was just the way to say that he was found reasonably
the judge found I that's how I have to start the sentence. Sorry.
The the literal construction of the English is getting in the
way here. The judge found there were reasonable grounds to believe
he essayed her and stalked her. There are no such reasonable
grounds for for a similar crime that would justify protective
order in Pink's case. >> Has Carl to just go on panels
and the whole thing is about on this guy. Now, if you think that's
okay, there's something wrong with you.
Even if you don't like Techone there, >> I there's a way
you can criticize Pink on this. And I I would actually criticize
Pink for letting this stuff go out like this. I do actually think
it was a mistake, but it doesn't have to do with protecting Tecton's
fragile ego at all. That's that's why he can't that's why Tactical
Templar can't conceive of the actual criticism you should levy
here, right? The actual criticism you should levy is, hey, you've
claimed that part of the reason you filed this protective order
is because you don't want his community harassing you. You just
want this to be done, right? This sort of flies in the face of
that that as soon as Tekton's community becomes aware of this,
they are going to be upset with you. You will get them brigading
your stuff again, right? So, it's just not smart to do. And it
it cuts a little bit against all of the stuff you filed the protective
order or sorry, some of your reason for filing the protective
order in the first place. That's like a criticism I could levy
a pink, but that criticism doesn't have to do with protecting
Techone. It's just like, "Hey, Pink, this isn't smart for you."
So, Tactical Templar can't come up with it, and none of these
ball washers will be able to come up with it. That's the actual
If you wanted to get mad at her, if you want to say, "Hey, that
wasn't good." That's why
there's something wrong with you. And if you are so so shortsighted
that you think, well, but I don't like this guy, so so this is
good. I don't like this guy, so this is good. So this should
be allowed in this instance. So if it happened to you, you'd
be okay with it.
Would you be okay if it happened to you?
If you if I was found if if a judge found there are reasonable
grounds to believe that I assaulted somebody, I would be okay
with this happening to me. Yes. Given that presupposition, given
that idea, yes,
that's that's the point. you had an ex-girlfriend
who falsely accused you or may I like falsely accused you of
this crime and and they were they were helping to try to ruin
your life after all this you gone through you'd be okay with
it. No, of course not. Of course this guy snotnosed
swagger. Of course they wouldn't be. But because >> this
guy hates Chronic Exotic. This guy hates
this Twitter account. this type of person is of the onedimensional
onenote mindset which is I don't like this guy so it's okay then
it's >> that's actually a better way to put it Jimberly
yeah exactly that is a better way to put it like I wouldn't be
okay with it I would feel like pretty up but that's the whole
point is like if I had murdered somebody and I was in prison
for life I would also feel like it was not good I would also
be upset by it but that's not the standard by which we judge
crimes hey what should the punishment for this crime What should
the punishment for this action be? Well, I'm going to try to
think if it if I was being punished, what would I like? That's
not NO, THAT'S NOT HOW YOU DECIDE THAT. Come on.
>> Well, let's use the protective order to get this guy
in trouble
now. Agreed. This is a stupid thing to do. But here's here's
my post. This is what I talk about all the time.
There are a lot of
simps that are guided entirely by their emotions. Thus, I don't
like Techone, so this is good and funny. It's not.
This situation sucks. She can talk. >> Yeah, dude. It's
so funny that there's a criticism here. It just has nothing to
do with Teone being a victim, and they can't see it in any other
light.
Dude, Teto is not a victim >> by their emotions. Thus,
I don't like Teone, so this is good and funny. It's not.
This situation sucks. She can talk about him, but he isn't able
to respond.
Whatever you think about Teone, everyone should be able to recognize
that this is not the way society should
>> Jimberly, I think you're you're taking his like slow
cadence as evidence that he can't read. I think he's like slowing
it down. I don't know. I'd have to hear him read another tweet
from somebody else. Okay. He is He's going very slow. Yeah, he
is going very slow, dude. Uh he just made me think of like a
fifth grader like following along with their finger as they're
reading. This
She
can talk
about him. So, of course,
of course, these people are the ones I'm talking about. Emotionally
immature,
weak, pathetic men. Bro, all you do is suck these losers. It
doesn't matter if this is something that these people, again,
15 minutes in front of them. This is something that these people
are too stupid to understand. I don't care if it's techone.
I don't care if it >> This guy's like the This guy's never
met a single on earth he can't empathize with. That's that's
his superpower. Okay,
you guys ever see you guys ever see the show Hannibal
with Will Graham? Okay, or read the books, either one, where
this guy has like an empathy disorder and he can like empathize
with serial killers and he can reconstruct their thinking. This
guy is Will Graham for instead of serial killers. Okay, this
guy's just Will Graham for he can reconstruct the the thinking
and the victim complex of any on earth. Okay, which makes it
particularly egregious that he's defending Tectone cuz he probably
knows. Okay, he's probably been able to enter his mind palace
and figure out that Tecton really did assault this woman.
He knows he could rebuild it. Okay, that's just how powerful
he is. It's Asmin Gold. I don't even care if it's Hassan
because I'm not a 65 IQ
idiot like you. I'm able to be like, wow, if we conduct society
based on a knee preference of I don't like this person, so anything
bad that happens to them is good, that is going to be detrimental
to society. And it's going to inevitably be used on people like
you and people like me. Because if the legal system is set up
where somebody can falsely accuse you, they don't even have to
provide any real evidence other than their own recounting, which
we have seen over the years that people's recounting, male or
female, is
let's just say shoddy at best. People misremember things. They
don't, you know, people don't really have the best recollection
and hindsight and they're they want to think about what I should.
Dude, what are you rambling about? What the is he rambling about?
We're not conducting society. Bro, why do you think everybody
waited until a determination was made by this judge? It's not
about how we feel. Well, for some people it is. Like, I don't
think I would stop thinking of techone as a even if he was found
not guilty. To be honest with you, it's just everything else
fits there. Okay, I I can feel it in my soul.
But most people waited until there was a judge's ruling that
found reasonable grounds to believe he salted pink. That's that's
how this works. That's why everybody's so in on it now. >> Would
have done rather than what I did do. Uh also the benefit and
the
People take that into account to try to frame the story that
that benefits them.
How on earth can you not see what I'm saying here? It applies
to you and it applies to me and it applies to Tech and it applies
to everyone. How hard is it not to tweet? I agree.
I agree. Are we serious right now? How hard is it not to go on
a stream and and talk somebody like this and do a whole segment
denigrating them? Why does she have to do that?
Why Why should her rights be curbed through her victimization?
Why, when she is the victim of something, if nothing else, the
stalking, which by the way, way beyond a reasonable doubt on
that one, okay,
why should she have her speech curbed? Again, which leads to
the actual criticism you could have here, that she should be
wanting to curb her own speech in this way because of the things
because of the reason that she filed the protective order in
the first place, right? Having to do with curbing harassment
from Teton's community.
But he he just can't get there. He can't get there. And I >> he
can't stop empathizing with the and so it's getting in the way
of the rest of his critical thinking capacity. >> I'm glad
that you uh Mr. Tim, I'm glad that you have this issolic.
I'm glad that you now have the self-control to not be an alcoholic.
But there was a point where
if that's true, then you were an alcoholic. Why why didn't you
just immediately stop?
No. The point is that there are people that have impulses that
have things that are wrong. And I agree that we should be helping
them to stop. I don't think Tech should have tweeted that.
I think he should have completely ignored it. But the fact remains
that this right here,
this right here is an attack on a person and the people
that's literally what the internet, what do you think the internet
is? What do you think Twitter is? Twitter is like 95% attacks
on people. You don't get to somebody and then say, "Oh, but don't
talk about me." Okay, that's not And listen, I've been really
careful with how I've been speaking the entire stream. I'm going
to stop being careful. I'm just going to say like what I think
and understand that it's with the caveat that like reasonable
grounds and all of this. It's just starting to get cumbersome
to stop and try to say it specifically every single time. Okay,
so I've done it like repeatedly, been super cocked about it,
but like what about her being a victim means she shouldn't have
to talk? Why? I need that explanation.
I need that from him. People that don't like Teeone are happy
about it, >> but I'm not. >> And it has nothing to
do with whatever feeling I have about Teone. And this is so simple
that it's honestly embarrassing that I have to explain it. It's
not about one guy. I don't know Johnny Depp,
but I didn't want to see Johnny Depp destroyed based on the allegations
around Amber Heard.
I didn't know the people who were involved in the Duke Lacrosse
situation.
But I didn't want to see these guys have their life and career
destroyed based on these allegations. I just don't
I
there's this weird cult
there's got to be some analog for this. There's this weird cult
of guys who just are totally lost in life who have nothing. They
don't have partners. They don't have prospects and all they do
is consistently
revictimize themselves thinking about what it would like what
it would be like to one day have and then be accused of something
like this and they talk about the Duke Lacrosse case, Johnny
Depp and what the mattress girl or something. There's like three
or four different fake cases that happened. By the way, you should
use Jean Gomeshi from Canada. That's a bad one. Okay. They they
just like Yeah, they're like they've got no prospects. They've
got no prospects. They've got no prospects in life and they constantly
revictimize themselves thinking about people who were wronged
and and falsely accused. Kevin Spacy, I don't think they use
Kevin Spacy. They don't like to think of themselves as gay. Okay.
It's just over and over again. I I don't care.
>> I think it's damaging to society when you have guys
that are in this position
>> it's like, okay,
they are
I found a way to turn this into an Israel analogy. They are
random Israelis who are more concerned about anti-semitism than
like thousands of people dying, thousands of civilians dying.
Okay. The harm on the other side that women have to deal with
in terms of like actual assault, not being able to get justice
for it is like a thousand times more than anything from like
the fake allegations. And they sit here revictimizing themselves.
Okay, we may have discussed we may have discovered like um like
or waiting neuroticism here where they're like they're just inventing
possible futures where they might be accused of rape. Okay, it
hasn't happened yet. As opposed to the people online who consistently
think of ways that anti-semitism might affect them in the world
and it never does and they're more concerned about that than
the people dying. Okay, it's the same pattern. I'm seeing the
pattern
>> The the court systems against me.
um social media is against me
and all of it requires no evidence to make some sort of accusation.
And then once the accusation is made, you don't even need the
evidence anymore because people will spread the false news, the
false information,
and that will stick to your name and there's nothing you can
do to undo it at that point,
which isn't fair. It it isn't fair to >> he says this.
Who has this happened to like I need better examples. Okay. Johnny
Depp. Nobody thinks Johnny Depp's anymore. Nobody Johnny Depp's
been like exonerated. And I don't even know if he should be exonerated.
Honestly, seemed like a mutually abusive relationship,
but he's been exonerated. Turkey Tom
Where are the people who are getting their lives destroyed and
there's just no evidence against them at all? Where? Where? Where
are these people? Who are
I need names and I need examples.
Cuz this guy, he he named like the women or whatever. A couple
of the women like the the what? The lacrosse case. Oh, the Duke
lacrosse players. Did those guys are their lives still destroyed?
Cuz listen, can we just make these people whole so these guys
stop treating them like victims? If there are people who got
their lives destroyed, that's bad. I don't think they should
have their lives destroyed. But I just don't see any evidence
of it happening in the Big 26. Okay, the big 2026. I've not seen
any evidence of this. I can't even think of something from 2025.
And they just it's going to be the same like weird culty behavior
of bringing up like these three cases they have and pretending
that oh but if this happened to me it would be >> Well
man, that that is the standard in which we operate. >> M
like kind of maybe the MI thing is a the MI thing all the evidence
is out there. It's like a dubious consent situation. He handled
it as well as he could. I think it's inappropriate to call him
a for it. Other people are going to do that because they just
hate him. All those people were saying bad things about Msk.
Everybody who's calling Msk a over the Emmy thing hated Msk already.
There's no change over there. There's no crossover.
Okay. They all hated him already. >> Says, "And yet he
still tweeted about her. Didn't this break the protective order?"
Yes, it broke the protective order that was put in place by a
far-left feminist judge. And that's not just me pulling it out
of the air. I went over this. The judge is somebody that had
to recuse herself because she was so biased. Now, should Tekono
have tweeted this? No. Should uh Pinky Chu have put this out
there. Should they all have come in to try to on Tee? No.
But there's a double standard here. What she did was fine. Even
though what she did is 10 times worse.
What she did was 10 times worse. And she should be charged. She
should be punished for this
because this is a provocation against somebody.
>> Wait. Oh my god. What the did this guy just say?
Wait, what? What she did is 10 times wor What? What?
Hold on.
but there's a double standard here. What she did was fine, even
though what she did is 10 times worse.
what she did was 10 times worse. And what did she do that's 10
times worse? I don't I don't know. What is this guy trying to
say, dude? I
I'm I'm lost now.
Just
the fact that she accused him with contemporaneous evidence,
with having let her friend know, all of this stuff is 10 times
worse. >> She should be charged. She should be punished
for this
because this is a provocation against somebody that can't >> She
should be charged for her speech.
Wow. It's
He's literally saying she's asking for it. I told you he could
empathize with any. Okay. This guy is the Will Gra of She This
is a provocation.
This is a pro. Dude, I think that's what Tone thought. That lip
filler that was a provocation to him. Okay.
what she did was 10 times worse. And she should be charged. She
should be punished for this
because this is a provocation against somebody that can't fight
back.
The art of character destruction and, you know, reputation damage.
By the way, this episode came out 3 days ago. Nobody saw about
nobody saw it. Nobody was tweeting about it. Nobody cared until
techone violated his protective order and then this whole thing
spun up.
Techone drawing attention to it is the thing that got his haters
to realize that it happened. Nobody cared. Nobody was tweeting
the clips. Okay, that's why this clip this morning from this
morning is the most popular clip of this. It wasn't until techone
freaked the out that people went, "Wait, why the did he do that?"
And then people had to go and look and they eventually found
this.
This slipped under the radar. Teone did it to himself. I would
love to hear what his response would be to that. >> It's
disgusting.
>> But again, all these people can do, all they can think
about, uh, bro got cooked so bad he broke the order. No, it's
when somebody's tearing down your reputation, it's the need thing
to do. And I I guarantee this guy shampoo, shampoo, whatever,
in the same situation would do the same thing. >> Shampoo.
You're
forever. Shampoo. Shampoo. YouTube. Change your YouTube channel
name right now.
Forever shampoo YTT.
I >> if if this guy had an ex and they were on online and
they had carp launch to say whatever they wanted and they went
out there and they accused him of all these things, guarantee
this guy would say something. Most people would say something.
The people that don't think they would say something are people
that >> I I maybe I'm just crazy here.
Am I I just feel like you could say something. Say it's not true
and then move on.
Right? Say it's not true and then move
>> Don't really understand the way that human beings work.
There is a compulsion to defend yourself if you think that you're
being wronged.
If you think that there's an injustice, there is a compulsion
to come out and defend
Uh Teto's deleted tweet. So So apparently he deleted the tweet.
Somebody got to him and said, "Maybe you should delete this."
I I mean at least that's good.
Makes a lot more sense. Teto messed up badly and violated the
protective order. But this is this is the way these people think.
They're not they're not really taking into into account what
she did. They're only looking at what he did based on the judge.
But that whole situation, that whole case, that whole dynamic
was fundamentally flawed.
And so what it tells you is that these people are okay
with the court system being weaponized against people they don't
like.
And they have no problem
with uh def
Why why was it weaponized? Why why you say it is weaponized?
It was used and the findings were
I I swear I just don't get it. Why Why does he totally ignore
this?
I did I not bring this up with him in our talk? Why did Tee say
that he had all the evidence to exonerate himself? If he had
that evidence, if he wasn't just lying,
why didn't he present it at the court case?
And why have we decided that that court case is weaponized?
Did So, even let's not even talk about the judge. I'm going to
I'm going to give you the judge for a second. Did Pink know she
was going to get that judge or did she file for a protective
order because that's what she sought?
She didn't know what judge she was getting.
She just filed it in the city she lives in or lived in, the city
they both lived in. matory rhetoric, uh, character destruction,
anything against people they don't like. There's no limit.
There's no limit. They want techone to be well, I would say Ruben,
Hold on, hold on. This is a good point from Ruben Rubin. If nobody
knew about it until the Techone thing, I'm not going to say nobody,
not literally nobody. I'm sure there are people who follow both
of them and I'm sure somebody like if he wasn't keeping tabs
specifically, I'm sure somebody does watch your content and was
just like, "Hey, she referenced you over here." I'm positive
somebody messaged the content to him,
right? Like that that seems like almost certain or he's following
their social media and saw it himself maybe, but
I don't think it's necessarily true that he's keeping tabs, but
somebody's keeping tabs and letting them know. And by the way,
Techone, those people aren't your friends. Okay?
Somebody sends you something, they're like, "Oh, hey, just so
you know, here's like a bad thing that happened that I think
you'll get really emotional about." Those people aren't thinking
about you. They're just looking for you to freak out. Okay? So
keep your head on a swivel. >> Put in jail for defending
himself in a tweet. It was an illconceived tweet.
But his point was it's very unusual again that she's saying that
he's like an incel
that he's some like he's some loser that was obsessed with
but according to her he he did some kind of egregious crime.
So again there's an inconsistency even in the premise.
So,
I I wanted to talk about this because I mean, hopefully he goes
to prison. Wouldn't that be funny? And it just again, it's the
shortsighted nature of what these people are doing. They just
don't get it. The these are the most dim
people I've ever seen. Um
um I'm I'm tired of seeing this goth uh girl for real. you know,
for a guy who talks so much about his ex passively
like, "Yeah." So, okay. Apparently, this guy is not a fan of
her. Um, so he
essay her but um he would not do anything with her because of
>> Okay, never mind. He's having a hard time reading now
that it's not stuff >> like Yeah. So, okay. Apparently,
this guy is not a fan of her. Um so, he
that's not This guy is not not a fan, dude. He He didn't He couldn't
read the tweet. He literally couldn't read the tweet. This guy's
not not a fan of Pink. This guy's not a fan of Techone. And he's
saying things that Teone said about Pink, right? Even at times
when the court case was pending, although I don't Yeah, I I believe
at times when the court case was pending, when the protective
order was already in place, he was saying these things, right?
And he's saying that if Teone is mad that she said he was like
addicted to or something that he is a that's what that tweet's
saying. essayer. But um he would not do anything with her because
of an anime addiction. [__] this person.
>> WAIT, I DIDN'T KNOW HE COVERED THIS. Nobody told me
he covered this. Let's >> The other part of it is this.
So, uh Kuimon, friend of the channel,
to this person. >> Oh, friend of the friend of the channel.
Well, Kuiman, let's go.
What What do you guys think Kooiman's
Digi evolution is?
What do you guys think he is he met Kuiman? I don't know. Interesting
to >> Take on uh what should happen to false accusers?
Broadly, women don't go around falsely accusing men. False.
False. They do it all the time.
>> Where? where
the does it not concern you that like the examples you try to
come up with are from years in the past
right he's like trying to figure out what he's like no false
it happens all the time like like the Duke lacrosse case from
Hold on when when was this actually wait I no we're fine we're
fine Duke
Duke Lacrosse
When was this? Duke lacrosse pokes 2006.
Does it not concern you that your prime example is from 2006?
Is that not Cuz listen, I understand that you got to go to 2006
to see if if uh to find like a really prominent case of this.
But let me ask you, when was the last time you heard about somebody
getting I feel like it was been since
Her debt was 2022. her debt was 2022 and
but I'm saying that if you want to go to 345 but yeah her debt
was 2022 in any case it's not broad women don't go around falsely
or sorry broadly women don't go around falsely accusing men of
women that's just is true >> it is a common occurrence
in fact it's so common that
I'm sure that everyone here can think of a high-profile example
>> that's not what the argument is if you understand what
you're reading broadly
outside of some some tiny percentage of cases. Women do not go
women do not go around falsely accusing men of rap.
I'm sure all of you could think of one.
Yes, nobody's disputing that.
And if you think that you are beyond this or you're too important
or you're too protected,
Brett Kavanaaugh, do you remember when Brett Kavanaaugh was going
through his confirmation for the Supreme Court? >> Do you
remember Christine Blloy Ford? Christine Blloy Ford came out
>> and it was nationwide news.
>> Brett Kavanaaugh is an animal. He's he's an abuser.
He he did all that like a devil's triangle or whatever it was
like
this woman had zero evidence. She didn't even recall the story
very well. 30 years ago somehow I ended up at this party and
Brett Kavanaaugh did this. Now
thankfully thankfully it didn't ruin his chance to become a member
of the Supreme
>> Why? We don't know what happened there.
you what would you do you think he should be the question I suppose
is do you think he should be on the Supreme Court if he's do
you think so
because if you don't if you think that's relevant information
and she believes she was raped by him then I don't think I don't
see what's wrong with her making that accusation
again all that has to happen and again oh wait two things okay
Brett Kavanaaugh massively undercuts his own point that it's
about destroying the person's life. Brett Kavanagh's life is
not destroyed. Brett Kavanaaugh is at the highest position on
the planet for somebody who is a judge.
There is no higher court in any land. There is nothing there's
nothing that weighs in on the state of the world more than the
United States Supreme Court. He has the most power he could possibly
have given his vocation.
His life is objectively not destroyed by any measure. You are
bringing up somebody who had this accusation. There wasn't enough
evidence to substantiate it and he went on with his life and
his life is totally fine. Your example actually destroys and
entirely undermines your point. >> I'm not saying that
whether you know he's a good member of the Supreme Court or not,
but
that was to a person
that's in politics that's a now a member of the Supreme
And that that level of allegation
was believed by the media there put forth by nearly everyone
nearly everyone was putting that forward
you know the the politicians
that there is an ounce of credibility. >> I again people
might have believed that but you have to look at the underlying
what happened what happened it came it went people pass people
said no no no
the evidence isn't strong we can't do anything about this and
they confirmed >> who was the other one um
you know
another Supreme Court
uh was it Clarence Thomas Clarence Thomas was another example
of an accusation that was
Now recently people think of like Johnny
>> I just I wonder where you would
what does he think he's the guy who thinks past his emotions.
He's the guy who thinks long term. What do you think the longterm
effects would be if we treated people who accuse someone of a
crime without sub full substantiating beyond a reasonable doubt
evidence? What do we think of these if if we demonize these people
and say they're false accusers for every crime? What? Dude, I
there are so many cases in life where like you need a police
investigation to even know, but the accusation is apparently
like you are demonizing the person unjustifiably
for accusing somebody of doing a crime. Does he realize that
very often somebody will accuse someone of a crime with no actual
evidence and then the person will be found guilty?
That's like the whole point of the system is there's an investigative
body that that handles looking into these things. He is suggesting
a standard here of if you accuse somebody and the evidence isn't
bolted on automatic, that person is guilty. You're actually a
false accuser.
He's not looking at the underlying reality. He's not looking
at what could possibly be the underlying reality or what could
what you could possibly prove, right? In a case like a case,
he's not looking at any of it. He's just basically saying if
you make an allegation and you can't substantiate it, you're
a false accuser. >> And stuff like that. But to say that
this doesn't happen, that they just don't go around making these
accusations is not true. And even in the event where it does
happen, it doesn't ruin your life. That's not true. There there
have been there have been guys that have been falsely accused
where they've lost everything. They've spent time in jail. Like
this is so dismissive of this problem. And I think I think there's
a fundamental issue here.
There's a fundamental issue of these people just not not wanting
to address reality. It's the same people that want to pretend.
>> Like I'm sure there are, but again, the argument is
broadly you you should read that as 99 or 99.9%
which you couldn't possibly disagree with. Well, look at the
stat. Go look at the statistics, okay? And tell me that you disagree
with that. >> The problems with uh illegal aliens don't
exist. It's not really that big of a deal. It's a it's an economic
benefit to have them here. These people are living in a delusion.
There's a hysteria around the idea of being falsely accused uh
born out of paranoia of this happening. >> That happened
to
unbelievably pathetic and indefensible thing. We have a situation
right here, >> by the way. Retweeted by this guy, this
snot-nos person
>> See, dude, he's going so slow. Does he realize that
he doesn't actually have to read these quotes? He could go to
the clip and listen to them.
Like, I understand this is difficult. This feels rough for him,
okay?
But you could just go to the clip and then somebody would say
these things for you. You don't even have to read them out. >> Then
a situation right here
where somebody is allowed to be falsely accused. They're allowed
to
they're allowed to go out there and then continue to disparage
and, you know, malign and insult the guy even more, but he can't
respond back. But no, it's it's just paranoia based on this person's
recollection, which is shardy best. The point is not about whether
the person deserves to suffer for what they've done. The point
is about what uh what situations do you create.
You want the barriers to reporting these things to be as low
as possible
and the risk to be low because you don't want a chilling effect
on crime that is already unreported. under reportported again.
Just dude, don't read. Go just Bro, there's nothing there's no
bigger indictment of your education system. Okay, guess what?
We can we can get a Cupid to show up and read on stream. Any
random Cubid you pick off the street,
you can read >> You want the penalty for
falsely accusing a person to be as high as
If you falsely accuse somebody to ruin their life and reputation,
you >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I think basically
everybody is okay with high penalties for, and it needs to be
incredibly incredibly specific. Well, I won't say everybody's
okay. If you had like if you had actual malice like an actual
malice standard like in defamation where this person knows and
admits like you you find out through leaked messages or something
that they are actually maliciously constructing this purely for
reputation damage purely to harm the person then I'm fine with
the penalties being high there
right I would be fine with like a slight additional penalty on
top of that that it's like something that has a low chance of
being proven either way and so the allegation can stick longer
that if there was But you could never make it so that any accusation
that's not fully proven out in court actually hurts the person.
Which by the way, like does he think that there would be a just
world where Pink Chu is actually punished for making this allegation?
Would he really argue that? That seems insane to me. And he says
like I think he would because he says, "Oh, what she did is 10
times worse."
It seems to be the case that he's arguing that she should be
punished. And I don't understand how you can get that. you should
have to face the years in prison that the person would have suffered.
And to to pretend this isn't a thing is just crazy delusion.
To pretend this isn't a thing. So the argument the way you you
think about this if you want to take Cleveland's argument and
seriously consider it. Okay. What is the purpose
of
the justice system? Is it to serve society or is it to
serve the person who is wronged or is it a balance? Okay. If
it if the purpose of the justice system is to serve the person
who is wronged and not society broadly, then I think a lot of
our sentencing doesn't make sense, right?
The whole point is like you want to you want to punish people.
You want to create a disincentive, but you also like you don't
want to be overly punitive for based on, you know, the victim
and and what they're thinking. This is there's this idea, I think
Queenman said it well here. Hold on. There's a hysteria around
the idea of being falsely accused of born out of a paranoia of
this happening. So, you can feel a sort of vicarious rage. It's
like
yes, you you empathize with the
or accused and you are
like thinking of how unjustified that would be and you feel like
oh these women should be stoned to death like Alex Gekkmo said.
Okay, that's what the tweet is that this clip is in reference
to. Okay, Alex Gekmo, this agamates guy saying well if you if
you falsely accuse somebody, you should be stoned to death. And
it's like I understand that as per somebody empathizing with
the falsely accused, but do we want a society where that happens?
And then what's the bar there? Right? Because the bar has to
be actually like straight up them admitting it to somebody else
essentially. Like like um
yeah, essentially like uh actual malice. That's what the bar
has to be because if the bar isn't that, right, it's knowingly
falsely accused. Yes. Knowingly it's it's actual malice. It's
the same standard, right, as defamation. That would have to be
the standard for any additional punishment. Basically saying
that unless you are telling somebody you're doing this just to
hurt the other person and that it didn't happen at all, you know,
it didn't happen. You are knowingly lying there. There can't
be any other standard there. And then in that case, it's like
does defamation not already suit for that.
because otherwise you are going to create a chilling effect and
there is a problem where people already don't go to the cops
because they know that that it's very difficult to prove where
they already don't talk about this kind of thing. Right? So societyy's
broadly most well served in terms of disincentivizing
like actually disincentivizing the original crime by not creating
this chilling effect. That is the argument. That's how you lay
out the whole thing. Okay.
that basically like women are already like victims of violence
significantly more than men. They already feel like they can't
report these crimes. And if you create this disincentive, if
you argue, oh well, we should stone these people to death. If
you're doing this, you're actually just creating a chilling effect,
you're creating like more you're you're increasing the likelihood
that more people are raped in the future. Okay? You're doing
your little bit >> to pretend we don't have at least half
a dozen examples off the top of our head. And I'm not even talking
about Johnny Depp like but that there's one but there are tons
of these fake examples.
Seems like every every time there's an accusation there there's
something off. There's something wrong. >> I've never met
a victim I didn't doubt. Every accusation I hear about it if
there's something off with this. I've never I've never seen a
victim I couldn't question. Every single one seems suspicious
to me. And it it hurts men. It does. It it definitely hurts men.
This guy is just
he's he's either super woke or he's I just don't I don't know.
Applying uh super hard penalties to somebody for falsely reporting
only makes it less likely that legitimate cases. So basically,
if you f this person is advocating that women who falsely report
and try to ruin men's life and reputation
shouldn't really have to face the consequences of what they're
doing. That is That is insane.
Seems like a pretty uh effing obvious take to me. I don't know.
>> Does he just play the clip people are having with Kuman
again that he doesn't cowtow people like are are you
He's spitting. Yeah, he's spitting.
>> Shameful that these guys live living
I mean just like >> dude he like can't read it. He can't
Oh no. He actually can't read it now. I didn't know. I thought
he was reading just fine when he made the post. Okay. But now
that he's reading other people's posts, he is having a difficult
time.
Living vicariously through a Bulgarian mut who modeled his life
after his
>> How are these people real? >> What a crazy defamatory
post from Styo.
What the man? A feopile. A feopile.
Like these people have to be the most dumb window licking degenerate
individual. You think that the bar should be you think that if
you make a false allegation that the
which incentivizes bad behavior you know
>> like the misk thing is actually the perfect example
here >> and I I hate to say this cuz um I don't hate to
say it but it sucks cuz I do feel bad for the consequences from
what Miz did but the way society should work is you should be
able to look at the emir story and misgive story and how they
come together and you should be able to say, "Okay, something
was miscommunicated here. Somebody was in their minds assaulted."
I don't think you could prove this beyond a reasonable doubt
in court. I don't think you would get this guy criminally convicted.
But that doesn't mean that Emir falsely accused him. That doesn't
mean that in her mind she was like, "Oh, I'm going to get this
guy." I don't think that's what happened. Okay? I think she probably
carried that with her. She probably felt like her consent wasn't
respected.
And it's like the job of everybody else to go, "No, it seems
like based on everything else going on here, he left. He He freaked
out. He left. He He wasn't attempting to violate your consent."
He misread the situation, but he was not attempting to violate
your consent, right?
And then Asmin Gold piled on instead. Yeah. They all they all
piled on and called Miser and then they get to complain now about
them being called or something. Very very goofy. Okay.
But like what should the penalty should because the tweet here
is arguing stoning to death and trust me there's probably no
better incentive for a lot of people on my side of the internet
then oh if we agree with Alex Gekmo here we get to stone Emiru
to death. Oh my
Wait wait a second. Maybe we judge this guy's argument a little
too harshly. But no Emirou shouldn't be stoned to death for falsely
accusing quote unquote. A lot of these things are gray. They're
gray. They're not knowable one way or another.
So the penalty for these people reporting stuff should not be
should not be maximal, should not be cra should not be crazy,
right? But he he seems to only have and again it's it's kicking
in where he only has empathy for
only empathy he has. He doesn't have any empathy for the person
who is pretty sure their consent was violated. They feel like
the person did it knowingly, right? And then they they have some
other interaction with the person where it becomes clear that
oh this person is kind of with me and they readjust how they
felt about the first time where they they were pretty sure it
was like non-consensual but you know I trust this person. They're
really nice to me in other situations. Right? That's that's the
manipulation. That's where they're delusional is they think positively
about the person and so they look past something bad that happened.
Okay?
And then when they realize how that person acts, who they are,
they go, "Oh, my initial gut reaction, that was correct." I mean,
this dude literally doesn't think mariju.
>> And these are the people that never ever should have
a say in society.
Never. because these people are dangerous
because they they believe well you shouldn't punish criminals
because then there may be somebody
who doesn't commit the crime who um who you know who who's
like are do you listen to yourself?
No, the punishment should be >> okay. I Why in Tactical
Templars's world, why don't you just cut the head off of everybody
who does a crime, a
Chop, chop, chop. No more head. You're gone. You're done. Done.
Out. If If the best way to handle crime is with the most punitive
measures possible, right? If we should just go after all people
who do crimes in that way, why why don't we why isn't that the
way it works?
>> Be severe. If you if you're speaking
if you are speaking false against somebody, the punishment should
be high. And then >> it's so thought-terminating to just
say, "Well, if it's false,
it hasn't been proven false.
It has not been proven false. Not even close." In fact, the preponderance
of evidence seems to lean in favor of it actually happening.
Like, if you had to bet on one side, you probably would bet on
the person who's got documented evidence of their lip filler
getting up and telling their their plastic surgeon about this,
right? who told a friend about it when she still was very much
in the relationship with Tecton such that Tectton freaked out
and made her like show all of her messages and call the friend
on the phone so he could listen, right? Like the preponderive
evidence leads me in a direction where he probably did this,
but I don't think he should be pun I don't think he should be,
you know, criminally punished for this unless it's provable beyond
a reasonable doubt. I don't know why he can't do the same thing.
Like there's no evidence beyond a reasonable doubt at all that
she lied. it. No court would convict her if it was just a straight
up did she lie about this? No shot she gets convicted. In fact,
I don't even think a civil court would convict her. But this
guy is sitting here pretending that it's just obvious she lied.
Obviously, well, if it's false, but it's not false. Nobody Nobody
can actually argue it's >> This person downplaying this
entire
I think reveals a major problem. It is It is a major issue that
you are not even willing to contend with this. Hey, how about
something from across the pond? How about the Muslim gangs? The
Pakistani gangs that >> let's go. I love Pakistani gangs
>> not only went unreported
but they were they were defended
by by the local government because they didn't want to be accused
of racism.
I How is this mapping on? They were That's I mean does Tactical
Templar realize that he is the local government in this analogy?
Does he realize that he is the British government? He's the person
who's like, "Oh, we don't necessarily want to look into this."
I don't know the whole story. Okay, I don't know the whole story
with that. But let's say it's true just cuz that's the world
he's operating in. So we could analyze his actual argument. Okay,
even if that were the case, he's the cops >> Like, do you
think do you think that
reduced the harm
in other cases? Do you think that soft on crime approach? Do
you think that benefited people
or do you think setting a standard that if you falsely accuse
somebody >> there's not a false accusation there.
So he's trying to argue that basically being soft on crime is
what a false like so there is no crime that is false accusation
right there's crimes for perjuring yourself which she didn't
do. There's crimes for
defam. Sorry, there's civil penalties for defamation. Is there
some is there some case where defamation can rise to a criminal
fact like a criminal finding? Is there some some laws in the
books in some places where you can actually be found um criminally
guilty for defamation?
So, society's decided that this is not a crime. So, his argument
has already failed. Okay. If we had it as a crime, she still
couldn't be found guilty of it. his argument fails again and
then he compares it to the Pakistani gangs on the idea that it's
light on crime. It's so it's not a crime but even if it were
even if it were you you have less proof that she falsely accused
him then you have proof that he like uh then you have proof that
I guess exonerating proof
right on his end
and we have to also factor in in my mind you also factor in the
fact that he lied about what proof he did have. Yeah. I don't
I just don't I
every layer of his argument fails. It's like he's literally just
signaling at Dude,
he's he's not actually making an argument, is he? I actually
think this is what he's doing. He is talking about how TTO's
a victim and then he just goes, "Well, uh Pakistani gangs Pakistani
gangs are bad, so I won. Pakistani gangs very bad. They're bad.
What do you want me to say? They're really bad. >> That's
that's like the level of argumentation that's happening.
>> It's like when you don't punish father, it's like Pakistan
gang. >> It's Dude, I
>> if you make a false allegation,
you're going to be held accountable. Do do you think
>> maybe maybe that's the appropriate way to handle like
I I'm looking at this
>> and it's just so incredibly obvious that there are people
that just don't care. They don't care about men. They don't care
about men's issues. They're just looking to simp or be perceived
of as one of the good ones. But I mean, the more that I look
at this, it's just it it's so obvious
that there there is no
there's no unified defense for men.
And that's unfortunately why men turn to Andrew Tate because
>> the convicted the actual
>> right I'm not wrong on that. Right. He is actually now
like found found guilty. I thought I don't want to I don't want
to jump the gun on it. Was he found >> Just oozing postules
like this guy. So
>> maybe I'll hold I'll hold back. I'll retract and then
I'll follow up. >> My final verdict, I would say, Techone,
you shouldn't have tweeted that. You know, you got a protective
order.
Um you shouldn't have done that. You should have handed it to
your lawyer.
You should have said, "You know what? If she's going to talk,
>> um, this isn't entirely true, Maximus. It just happens
to be the the weight is higher for being caught than it is for
the penalty. Most people who commit crime aren't really capable
or the the vast majority of people who commit significant crime
are actually too stupid to really consider the long-term consequences
of the crime they're they're they're committing. And so that
is why they commit crimes, basically.
But the penalty does have an effect. It's just not it's not the
vast majority of the what factors in >> maybe I need a
protective order because she's she's defaming me and I'm not
allowed to to talk back. Maybe maybe finally something to get
a protective order yourself so that neither of you can can talk
about this
because what she did there is absolutely unacceptable. So he
he can't defend himself now. And if he does well techone's going
to jail because he's f
H there's another aspect of this that's actually quite funny.
This is a little bit like dude, could you imagine if Tactical
Templar was making content and following the Destiny sphere back
in 2021
and he was like out here arguing that Mr. Girl should criminally
charge Destiny and maybe forethought for banning him from the
subreddit cuz people were talking about him and he wasn't allowed
to defend himself. Could you imagine?
Could you imagine >> violating the protective order? A
man who can't defend his reputation,
a man who can't They already took away his right to defend his
life. He can't defend his life. He's not allowed to own
So if if one of these freaks that hates him goes to his house
and and he's already been swatted, by the way, but if one of
these people >> He hasn't been swatted. He hasn't been
swatted. He's got a whole bunch of security cameras. Nobody came
in with rifles. That's not what happened. Okay.
You know who's actually swatted? I think recently was uh was
Destiny, right? Didn't those cops come in with like rifles and
I think those cops actually had rifles and they rolled in with
like rifles and stuff. That's actually swatting. When when you
call in like a like a police visit or whatever and they don't
show up with rifles, you have not been swatted. You have been
inconvenienced. It is bad. It's probably some low-grade danger
in that all cops are apparently capable of murder in the United
States at the drop of a hat. But the swatting is what's actually
dangerous. That they're coming in expecting danger at a heightened
level of like uh
what's the word? Vigilance, right? I only saw sidearm drawn.
No rifles. Okay, but they had guns out. Okay, I'll give them
guns out. Maybe they didn't have rifles. No, that one of them
had a rifle for sure. I'm almost positive one of them had a rifle.
Took a break and my buddy told me techone is going to jail for
subweeting our queen. Pinku pinky kachu. I forgot her name. We're
so back, baby. This one time just for fun I will go. Wait, you
don't know who it is. It's Pink Shu. You don't know who Pingchu
is? >> This is Pingchu.
>> You didn't know this is Pinku? This is Pingchu right
here.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. That's pain. >> Come into
his house knowing he's disarmed. He can't really properly protect
his family. But more than that, now they don't even want him
to be able to protect his name. And I think that's that is a
step way too far. Yeah. >> Why? Dude, this is like so fundamentally
not conservative. It's very funny.
Conserv imagine I just went I conservatives will tell you, "Oh
man, we should see what did this guy say? Has this guy ever done
content on George Floyd? Has he ever given an opinion on George
Floyd before?" Right? cuz this is very much like the he's treating
Teone basically like um
like leftist treated George Floyd right trying to ignore who
in his mind in his worldview like if you're a conservative you
think that leftist with George Floyd said oh well yeah I don't
care that he had fentinel in the system I don't care that he
was like being ory or whatever they only analyze like the one
act right
a conservative way of looking at this is well we're going to
go all the way back in the causal chain You know what I'm saying?
And he's not doing that at all, which is interesting.
He's not going back at all. Like, he's not looking at any of
the preceding factors. It's like, dude, why did this happen,
though? Why did this happen, man? Okay,
again, he's he missed the whole criticism, the actual criticism.
I think we're basically at the end of >> I think that this
situation and some people will say, "Oh, you're just writing
tectum." No, it's nothing to do with Tectum. And if if you're
genuinely too stupid to understand that what I'm saying applies
to you and everyone else, that it's not just one person. It's
not it's not glazing one person. It's not grinding one person.
It's not standing up for one person. It is for
society. It's for men. I just Yeah. I I I want
Dude, men have like struggles. I don't know why you wouldn't
pick a real struggle men have. You're like, if you want to help
men, there's so many things you could do. This feels like the
the worst case. Like, this is you're going to help men by taking
some, I guess, like whiny manchild who constantly victimizes
himself and like just leaving it all in the field for this guy.
How How are you helping any real man
There's just no there's no like average guy who benefits from
this at all. If anything, you make men look worse by
The struggle is real. Okay. All right. Done with that. Well,
sorry. Done with that. Apparently, he pulls it up later. Apparently,
we're actually not done with Tactical Templar quite yet. All
right. Apparently, he does pull up this tweet again a little
bit later. I do want to check it out really quick. All right.
>> here, I'm going to >> uh basically that I did
on the situation. Wait, why is he Why did he pause and do a new
Oh, cuz he's live recording, right? So, he hits his intro.
>> Brothers, I want to do a follow-up to a video that I
did on the situation with >> Let's Let's go. Give me two
seconds. I'll be right back. >> Uh with Techone.
So, I I talked about this very very briefly in another video
where
uh basically
Teone's ex-girlfriend went on this panel and everyone there was
just making fun of Teone, you know, basically saying that he's,
you know, almost like an incel. He's addicted to, you know, like
going off on Tee.
Now, Teone has a protective order, so he can't really say anything
in response to this, which I think is just wildly
that your ex-girlfriend can go and talk about you on a panel
like this and you can't respond.
And so, uh, people
people are like reveling in this. They're they're enjoying it.
Even though it's destructive to culture, even though it's destructive
to other men
that you're just able to go out there and disparage a guy, he's
not able to respond and protect his his name. >> Wait,
what's the follow? Hold on. He's just reintroducing what's the
followup >> reputation? So, uh, Teone did respond,
and he didn't he didn't call her out by name, but he did point
out one of the things that was very inconsistent about this,
that you have somebody that claims that Tekone is like this lustful
animal
and that he just forces himself on you all the time. But then
at the same time, you say that he's basically an incel and that,
you know, you wanted something from him and he would never do
it. Like it's very weird. Okay. And here's what I said in response.
This is what I talked. >> Okay. This is the same video.
This is literally the same video. Why do the video again?
>> There are a lot of short-sighted Sims that are guided
entirely by emotion. Thus, I don't like techone. So, this is
good and funny. It's not.
>> Oh, is he re-shooting the same video because he couldn't
read the first time? Is he going to do one where he's like psyched
himself up? He's getting ready to read this thing over again.
>> This situation sucks.
She can talk about him,
but he isn't able to respond.
Whatever you think about Teone,
every one of you should be able to recognize that this is not
the way society should operate, which is true. Take Teone out
of this. Insert anyone that you actually like. Okay?
Somebody has an ex-girlfriend that you like. Okay? I I don't
know who that person would be. Just imagine somebody that you,
you know, you're friends with or, you know, an actor you like,
a content creator you like.
Maybe maybe we'll say PewDiePie. You know, I saw something about
PewDiePie recently. You say PewDiePie.
He's he's vaguely pointing at this sense that there's an injustice
felt that somebody's being who's not allowed to defend themselves,
right? There's an injustice felt there. But if you only stop
there and you don't do any further analysis that like that can
sound okay, but that's not what's happening here, right? You
have to take one step further back in this causal chain and go
to why can't he say anything? Why did he give that ability up?
Right? There is an asymmetry that feels wrong if you don't look
into it any deeper. Now for him, he believes there's cope about
an activist judge, right? That's how he gets rid of the but nobody
else should believe that. You shouldn't believe that. Okay, that's
not what happened here.
This protective order was going to get granted. Tect looked horrible
on the stand. Tect's case, his evidence in his favor was nothing.
He put, he said, 15 minutes into looking for stuff. That's after
he explicitly stated that he had exonerating evidence for himself.
And then he went he showed up to court and went, "Well, I only
took 15 minutes to look through tweets."
this protective order would have been granted by anybody. He
did nothing to show that he wasn't doing something bad. He basically
admitted he was stalking her and he also admitted that he is
like an unmedicated schizophrenic. It it was over from the moment
that trial happened, okay? with with the amount of prep he had,
the amount of evidence he had, he had no chance.
>> Say that an ex-girlfriend of PewDiePie from years ago
is like disparaging him and calling him all these names and insulting
him, calling him a creep. And he's addicted to that, he's an
incel, he's this and that.
And she's allowed to do that with all of her friends and do it
on a panel and people can broadcast that. But PewDiePie, he goes
to respond and be like, like, come on. Like, this doesn't make
sense. This is inconsistent.
He tries to protect his name and all of a sudden,
all of a sudden, people come after him. It's like, wow, your
ego is so small. You're so pathetic. You like the inability to
defend yourself. This is a serious matter.
So this guy Substance comes back and
>> "Oh my god, why
substance owns this guy?" >> um he earned this badge. He
should wear a ply, which by the way, this is defamation. Make
make no mistake. This is absolutely defamation. Um you're accusing
him of a crime that he hasn't been convicted of. >> Absolutely
disgusting. If I see this substance guy, it's on site. I'm banning
this guy from my community. If I see him again, okay, it's on
site. Absolutely disgusting. Total defamation.
What a piece of >> and a protective order. >> Absolutely
piece of >> by a judge like this is not the same as um
it just isn't the same as a conviction. No matter how much you
wish it were true, it's just not.
>> It's not. But given a couple of the different factors
here, I do believe that somebody actually calling Tone on Twitter
is not guilty of defamation. They're not, sorry, is not going
to be found liable for defamation. They're not going to be, you
know, bouncively liable in any way. >> So, let's take a
look at some of the >> How hard is it not to tweet uh LMA
or are we serious? She's able to publicly defame him forever
and he's unable to do anything about it. It should have been
a criminal trial
where he was jailed.
But there's no way why
like immediately I just asked why why do you think I need a criminal
charge to to accuse somebody of this to say this? I think he's
judge found there's reasonable grounds to call him. I'm going to
call him. Simple as.
I don't not think it's true. I totally think it's true.
No actual malice. Where are you where are you going to go now?
What are you going to do now? >> Evidence of that. This
is a classic he said, she said. And the benefit of the doubt
was going to the female.
That is >> the benefit of the doubt goes with the person
who brought evidence to the court >> It's true.
That is true. And the reason why I'm so viferous against this
has nothing to do with techone. It's the fact that it could happen
to anyone.
>> it literally dude it's so funny that he didn't watch
the queen clip. He just listened to the quote and he is quite
literally doing the exact thing that was described in that clip
that you are doing this to feel some kind of vicarious rage for
all men.
Like you're hallucinating more false accusations than actually
exist so you can feel vicarious rage on behalf of men and continue
to hate women on your stream the way you always do with every
other content creator too.
That's it. You're just transparently doing that right now. It's
It's actually crazy that he just wouldn't read it. >> False
allegation and then a court system that has a propensity towards
siding with one gender over another based on my feelings and
then you have somebody that lost their ability to defend themselves
uh both physically and they can't even defend their good name
online. Now you say good name. I'm not I'm not saying that Tech
has a good name. I'm saying the the phrase protect your good
name. This is something that's unacceptable
and it should be unacceptable for everyone
whether you like Teone or not. But I again I think that some
people
are
so invested
in not liking a person and then virtue signaling off of it that
they lose they lose themselves. Bro, all you do is suck these
losers
dicks.
>> So he's the second time he's reading this tweet today.
Very cool. This guy's a like. This is a 60 IQ take.
Genuinely 60 IQ take. >> Hovers over PFP.
This is a 60 IQ guy. 60 IQ take. I see you. I see you, Tactical
Templar. I see you. >> Like, how how dumb
to be >> to not see that this could be used against you
or anyone else.
>> Keep gawking.
And yet he still tweeted about her. Didn't this break this protective
order? Yeah, he shouldn't have done it. But the fact is that
the situation itself shouldn't be.
This isn't fairness. This isn't justice. She can defame him,
but he can't say anything.
If Te wanted to talk, >> it's not defamation. Come on,
bro. This guy objectively
don't make me public. Hold on. Hold on. You're accusing this
person of defamation. I don't know if that's fair.
>> himself has a history of liking and talking about characters
that went as low as 6 to 8 years old. While >> I'm sorry,
this clip is always relevant. It's coming up again. >> In
a waifu tier list. >> Next up, Pon. Dude, I feel like
were to visit me, I feel like we'd just be best friends,
>> you know? And I bet she would taste
>> Imagine how Pon's feet would taste when she's 18. Probably
like cinnamon and honey. Uh, should be fine. B4. I can't believe
she's not butterful. Chi-chi. >> Why you got to talk, dude?
Why you got a defeat thing in there, too? It's so bizarre. To
begin with, it's a waifu tier list, by the way. This character
doesn't exactly look old. This character doesn't look old at
all.
>> Very concerning. Okay. Very concerning. >> Hilarious.
Cute. Get this girl a Cocoa Goat. Okay. She is adorable. She
is beautiful. Dude, this girl is already running a hotel at >> Dude,
I remember I watched this clip with Straight Right here on the
stream. Do you guys remember her reaction? We just watched from
like here to like where where he's like, "Oh, she's nine. She's
already running a hotel." Do you remember Straight Right's reaction?
Straight's reaction was, "Oh, well, that's kind of like wholesome.
Maybe it's not so bad."
>> Yes. Cute. Get this girl a cocoa goat. Okay. She is
adorable.
>> She's like, "Oh, that's like that." Hold on. Pause.
Wait. That's kind of like wholesome, actually. That's like That's
not so bad. That's like wholesome. >> She is beautiful,
dude. This girl is already running a hotel at LIKE AGE SIX.
>> OH, like he's just talking about how awesome she is
as a little that more men should be comfortable like complimenting,
you know, young women or or even little girls like this. There's
like a She's like, "This is straight's reaction." Okay. And then
Tek's got to throw this one out. >> Patch 2.0 when we gather
the Dragon Balls and we revive Chi-Chi and then she gets to expand
to level 18 and age 18. Imagine how amazing she would be. >> Fell
for it to get award. Fell for it to get award.
Dude, it's so weird, man. He's so weird. He's so WHY ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT THE LITTLE girl being 18? Why are you trying to
do this right now?
WHAT IS GOING ON? WAIT, TETO, could you explain that to me? What
What changes when that little girl turns 18? What are you thinking
about that would change when she turns 18? Is it that she'd be
able to like drink with you? No. Is it that she'd be able to
go to the casino with you? No.
Is it that she'd be able to,
I don't know, vote? Was it about voting? Oh, no. It was a waifu
tier list. Oh, well, what would you do with a waifu that they
could only do with you once you turned 18 that would like give
us a window of insight into what you could have been thinking
about? What would that be exactly? Something you do with a
>> when they turn 18. >> Rean Ruben donated $3. Bro
is about to ring out the carpet in that hotel for the feet sweat.
>> Why talk [__] about his ex? Maybe he shouldn't
for the money
this is this is a midwit
um a midwit response.
So because you have deemed him guilty of this, he has no right
to defend his name. He has no right to defend himself ever.
You're a idiot. And just understand, I know you're an idiot.
You know you're an idiot. And now everyone else is too. Tecton
isn't gonna bang you consensually.
It's just such stupid trip. Like
these are the people by the way. He him. These are the people
that makes societ. >> He him. He him. >> Worse for
everyone.
>> The he.
>> I THOUGHT YOU LIKE GUY. I thought you like men.
That's a he him. Bro, why you coming after the heims?
What the? >> You can't instigate something and then play
the victim. It's childless af. I don't watch Teone or know anything
about the situation, but all I can see these days from YouTube
streamer culture is just toxic egos.
These women are all giggling like high school girls. Uh 26 drama.
It's sad. Yeah, I agree.
>> What are you talking about? It's
He can't talk about her because he lost due to his own words
in court. She didn't even roast him. Everyone else
>> She kind of roasted him though. She did do the thing
that now she got put onto that. She wasn't directing it there.
She got put onto that. Okay. But she did kind of roast him with
the Just be real. >> She did.
She literally did. You just made that the up. Like they were
all making fun of him. They were all mocking him and he can't
even defend himself. He shouldn't have lost a court case. He
didn't. There wasn't a There wasn't a court case.
>> Yes, there was. And he lost.
There objectively was a court case. It happened in a court. I
could give you the name of the court if I wanted to go look it
up. There literally was a court case. You're saying there wasn't
a criminal case. That was that was a civil case for a protective
order. That wasn't to determine his guilt or innocence.
Genuinely, I am worried about the
>> Why do I need him to be guilty, found guilty in a criminal
court of assault to call him this? Why is that your standard
of evidence? Why? Why is that your standard of evidence >> of
this country and our species when we have people this stupid
that are going out there and making these sort of declarative
statements? It was not a court case. It was based on
that declarative statement is objectively true.
That declarative statement is objectively true and you are soying
the out about it. He shouldn't have lost the court case then.
You know what? Do you know what this guy's saying? This guy's
saying he should have lost the court case. Then if he wanted
to talk about her, that's true. That is all true. If he wanted
to be able to talk about her, if he wanted to be able to defend
himself online, he should have brought all of that evidence he
said he had. But he didn't. >> A judge's interpretation
and the judge,
if you recall,
the judge was a far-left feminist
somebody that had an issue with this particular thing.
I I don't mean an issue in terms of a moral issue, but she was
>> um he's technically this is true, Maximus, but he wasn't
found civily liable in this case. The He was found um
there were reasonable grounds to believe that he assaulted and
stalked her >> that was
accused from another case because she was that biased. >> I
believe Wait, if they thought that, why didn't they ask her to
recuse herself from this case? I think judges basically don't
want to ever try to argue this. They don't want stuff overturned.
That's like a judge's biggest fear is that something gets overturned.
If somebody accuses them of bias, very often if there's any like
any grounds to it whatsoever, they will say, "Oh, I'll just reduce
myself then. I'll just give you somebody else." They don't care.
They got a whole they're they're like working on an assembly
line, okay? They'll let somebody else take the case
unless it's like a very high-profile case and they want to be
the judge on it, right? But if it's just like a random case,
they'll just Yeah. They'll just peace out, man.
Tones Teto's lawyers didn't ask for >> You're simp taking
pity on effing rapist. No. No. That's not true at all. That's
false.
You're not taking pity on somebody that did something.
I'm making the claim that he didn't do that. Therefore,
it's not defending the action. It's saying he didn't do the
But even more than that, he has not been found guilty in a court
of law. Do you understand that this is still defamation? and
her
insulting him. >> Didn't Wait, didn't he look this up?
What did he look up on chat GBT when we talked? He looked something
up on Chat GBT when we talked.
I could have sworn it was the
Maybe I looked this up by
cuz I've looked it up before and Chat GBT will just straight
up tell you like, "Oh no, you're going to have a rough time if
you try to argue that that um this person is defaming you." It
it recommends you don't do it because they could sue you, but
it's not that you would lose. It's that TeeOne, they it literally
said when we looked it up, Teone doesn't have a high likelihood
of winning at all.
It's like you should avoid it cuz you don't ever want to go to
court, but if he does sue you, he's not likely to win at all.
>> And berating him on that show where he can't defend
himself,
it's crazy. Don't forget to wipe.
I mean, honestly,
going through this list, >> dude. Uh, why did he read that?
Why did he read that one? Have you ever seen a more pathetic
group of people? They have no duty of care of what they're saying.
>> They've never really thought about this.
>> Papa Gut and Taku still own you.
>> Papa Gut got absolutely humiliated by Andrew Wilson.
>> That's That's something.
Maybe he shouldn't have warranted
Maybe he shouldn't have warranted a reason for a protective order.
Hey, dumb. Hey. Hey, S. A protective order is because she's in
fear, right?
that's You don't get a protective order because you're just in
fear. That is not why a protective order is granted. That might
be why she applied for it. That's not why it was given. She's
Do you apes? You imbred deg.
How the in the world do you talk down to people? Uh, actually
they gave her a protective fork cuz she was in fear. That's what
he thinks in his mind. That's the way it works. She went to a
judge who was like, "I'm really scared. I'm really scared. Please
protect me." And the judge was like, "This guy can't talk about
you and he can't own guns for 10 years." That's not how this
works, brother. Not even a little bit.
Not even a tiny bit. generate. Do you understand that a protective
order is because she claims she's in such fear of tee that he
has to be deprived of a gun? She is so afraid of him that if
not
um she she's just afraid that he's going to go crazy and hurt
her. Do you understand that's what a protective order is? But
>> it's not just you're you're framing it entirely wrong,
right?
You can have totally irrational beliefs. No judge are orders
your guns taken on the basis of an irrational belief. Okay?
In fact, the entire point of the protective order trial is to
figure out if there are reasonable grounds to suspect he committed
the the acts that he's accused of which the judge did and then
they or they issued the protective order.
He's totally disconnecting that element, right? He's just going,
"Oh, well, she was really scared. She was really scared and then
they give they gave her a protective order." That's not how it
works. But apparently >> I will I got to cut that voice
completely. I can't even though even though it's a it's like
a voice that is appropriate. I got to cut that voice out >> She
feels so comfortable
>> talking about him publicly
that she'll do it on camera with a bunch of people with with
a big laugh.
If that doesn't tell you that she's full of I don't know what
the to tell you.
A protective order is to protect her because she's in fear of
her life. She abused that system
and that district and that judge
in order to get this decision.
And then what does she do? Provokes the guy that she's apparently
terrified of. Is that what you do? You're terrified of you're
apparently you're so terrified. If if Tekton says anything about
you, you like you have this like winter soldier like you're like,
"Oh god. Oh god. He was going to come after me." You're apparently
so terrified that you go out in public and you [__]
on a guy. Do you ever stop and think about how you are? Do you
ever stop and think like really think about how dumb you are?
No. The fact >> the funny thing is I've done that. I've
been like, "Dude, I'm I've been in situations where like dude,
I'm I can't imagine being the guy who's never thought that before.
You got to be a special creature to have never thought that."
Okay, >> dude. You people don't. Nicad you that's pretty
much my response is don't you wait do you not >> care you
don't care about te you don't like him so anything bad that happens
to him is justified in your mind even though he hasn't been convicted
in a court of law he's been convicted in your underdeveloped
brains
you're shut in underdeveloped brains so therefore he doesn't
have to be convicted in a court of law I convicted him whoever
it is uh uh Regis Philin
A random anon with less than 300 followers with a cat eye.
>> Wait, no way. Hold on. Hold on. This is unfair though.
This is actually totally unfair because I know a bunch of people
follow this guy cuz he's a L cow. That's actually up, bro. This
guy's got this guy's got like 30% more followers and he's That's
crazy.
Okay, that's fine. I I was really hoping he'd be under 300, but
he's not. So
>> has determined the techone is guilty. Therefore, if
somebody defames him or insults him and berates him, they should
be able to do it and he shouldn't even be able to respond.
These people are weird and they're pathetic. An actual Here's
your oppression, dumb fug. Oh no. The man who essay the his girlfriend
at the time can't respond to a roast. Uh yeah. Yeah. his free
speech is being violated because he can't defend his
And if if he is uh I if he is >> his free speech is being
violated because despite an order being granted blocking him
from her, he continued to do so repeatedly.
It on a temporary order that they requested extensions on because
they hadn't gathered the evidence they needed to go and prove
his innocence. right to go and make the argument that this shouldn't
be granted further. Okay. On the temporary version, which I guess
it's always a temporary version technically, but on the the initial
temporary version that was supposed to be very short. Okay.
He couldn't control
That's why this was extended, why it was granted and extended
for so long because they do it on an emergency basis for a short
period of time before having a hearing where they'll determine
whether or not they should grant it for a longer period of time.
Well, on that short period, he violated the order
That is why this happened to him. I just I don't know, dude.
The idea that there's just nothing nothing happened. This is
there's no reason for it. Okay. >> Yeah. His free speech
is being violated because he >> his free speech is being
violated >> can't defend his reputation
>> because no analysis. His free speech is being violated
for a reason. It is, but it's not because he can't defend himself.
It's because he has shown a propensity to have no regard for
the law, for the legal system at all. And when a judge tells
him, hey, you can't do this for a very short period of time,
he's incapable of following along. That level of
the total lack of impulse control is a factor in granting a further
protective order. Hey, this guy's incapable of controlling himself.
I actually have to extend this. If this guy thinks it's at all
appropriate for him to for him to contact this woman, for him
to threaten this woman, he will continue to do so. I have to
make it incredibly clear to this person that they can no longer
do this is what the judge thought.
And if if he is uh if he is as guilty as you say, he should be
in jail. Why is he not in jail? You inbred Mongaloid.
You have a Spongebob avatar.
You're a socialist. Unapologetic.
You're a socialist. You're a socialist. How embarrassing. It
says um
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. He he has violated the temporary protective
order multiple times. Charging Jim.
There was a temporary order given issued in September. He seeth
about her multiple times since publicly
since that initial temporary protective order was file filed.
Right. I believe it's at the end of August of 2025. and he sees
about her multiple times. Yes,
>> Uh
did she
uh name him or did people who know uh the type of person he is
connect the dots and rightly dunk his ass for it? How vague does
the description have to be before we're allowed
to use the knowledge? That's silly. Did he name her? Come on.
Reread the the latter half of my response. People are rubbing
their brain cells together and thinking for themselves, which
rub your brain cells together.
>> I'm saying the same thing. >> He didn't say he
he how is he going to break the protective order if he didn't
use her name? You're saying the same thing. How vague does a
description have to be to where we're allowed to use our our
knowledge? Oh, I don't know. Um her talking about her her past.
They're both talking about each other. Yes.
>> Boyfriend. Like,
uh, how >> is he slurring? I don't know. That tends to
just be his speech naturally. That's like his natural way of
speaking. I don't know how else to That's just how he naturally
talks like this. He talks like Donald Trump, but I don't think
he's like over four. >> How are you, Torias?
To toas.
The clip is her talking about her ex,
a previous a previous person she was uh she was involved with.
The person was bald. The person, she says, um,
apparently didn't touch her very much and he was obsessed with.
>> She didn't say that. Other people inferred that. Well,
actually, no, she might have said it when she says the he was
really um he liked anime girls. I guess she implies that >> anime.
That sounds vague. His post was way more vague. >> Neither
one is vague. Neither one.
>> But I mean th this is this is what these people are.
It's crazy to me.
>> Why are you complaining about simps when you are one?
>> Oh man. >> I'm not a s. I'm out here fighting
for men. Yeah, you're like sing for men. The difference is that
you
of an ugly bold guy with a
I'm I'm sing because I reject your entire premise that it's good.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on. Does tech has te been found
guilty in a criminal court of having a
if not that's defamation
>> that a guy should be able to be maligned and slandered
and defamed
and have no recourse to be able to defend himself.
That's that's what you deem as
I I mean I I'm telling you these people are just dumb. And the
thing is,
I will reiterate it again because I know that a lot of you people
are dumb. It has nothing to do with Tactone himself. If some
if some person is falsely accused of something, even if you don't
like him a lot, like I really don't like this person,
they still deserve the benefit of the doubt until convicted in
a court of law. And if somebody says something on them,
they should be able to respond. >> Why does Tactical Templar
think that his opinion on this outweighs the legal system that
everybody like participates in the democracy that has created
and shaped that legal system? Like why is his opinion worth more
than everybody else's is my question. Like literally
the the society has decided how this is handled, what rights
can be taken away given a certain set of actions. Why do you
think your opinion, which has no basis? You're just arguing it's
unfair without engaging whatsoever. Why does your opinion outweigh
what the general society's decided? Like you could just as equally
stand out here and say, "Well, I think, you know, I don't think
murder is that bad." Really? If you murder somebody who Let's
do this. You murder your wife because she cheated on you, I don't
think you should be charged. It's like, cool. That's a fantastic
opinion. Keep it to yourself. Nobody cares. Nobody shares it.
It's totally
shut the up.
You're just arguing against what already the thing that exists
has been decided by multiple people. The fact that they could
take his guns away. Supreme Court decision 81 or 90.
Okay. It's like he's just totally ignoring the fact that we've
we've decided this as like a well you've decided as a country
and as a state. Why why do you ignore all that? It's techn had
his second amendment violated,
his first amendment violated.
Like everything has been violated from this guy all because this
girl needed a protective order for a guy that she's clearly not
afraid of.
She has no fear of this guy whatsoever, obviously. So, spare
me. >> Why do you think she's lacking fear? Can we ring
our Could we rack our brains? Why do you think she's no longer
afraid?
Might it be that some legal measures have been taken to restrict
how Tet can react to things? Might that be a part of the reason
that she's no longer afraid?
>> Your ridiculous faux indignation and
And I will say this, if Tek is guilty of any of this stuff, then
let her go to the police, arrest him, prosecute him, let him
have his day in court. If he's found guilty, he should go to
jail. If he's innocent,
then he should go free, and he should be able to sue all of these
different people that are accusing him of of a crime. That's
really that's really what it is. This is so simple. It's unbelievable.
But you do not get to sit and be judge of somebody because you
don't like them. >> That's actually totally wrong.
It's totally wrong. That's literally what he does when he talks
about Pokemon, right? That's what he does when he talks about
a whole bunch of people on his channel. He sits in judgment of
people cuz he doesn't like them. He can argue it's over the actions,
but all of us would argue it's over the actions, too. Ultimately,
if you're just going to ignore that and boil it down to, well,
you just don't like this guy, then we're all doing the same thing.
And if somebody is going to go out there and defame a person,
they should be able to protect their name. Now, honestly, I would
have uh I would have forwarded that uh clip
>> to a lawyer.
>> Yeah. That's what I would have done if I protect forward
this is like, "Hey, she's
she's coming after me. Can we can we file a protective order?"
That's what I would have done in that situation. I wouldn't have
advised him to tweet at all, but people like, "Oh, oh, look.
Teto viol violated his restraining order or his protective order.
It's so pathetic. Bootlickers
because you don't like a guy.
>> Okay. I mean, realistically, I'm going to stop this
because he's going in circles. I understand he's been going circles
for in circles for a while, but I told somebody that I can get
more than two hours out of the Techone stuff. And just like that,
just like magic, I've I've made three hours out of it. So there
it is.